Bueno, a ver, imagínate esta situación. Una profesora de primaria, ya jubilada, de 74 años,
sale de su casa para hacer una compra superrápida en la tienda de la esquina. Una mujer con 16
años de educación formal, o sea, toda una vida dedicada a moldear mentes jóvenes.
Claro, una persona completamente... funcional, digamos.
Exacto. Pero resulta que horas más tarde, un vecino la encuentra a 10 cuadras de distancia
y está angustiada, muy desorientada y literalmente no tiene idea de cómo volver a su casa.
¡Wow! Qué desesperante para la familia.
Totalmente. Y lo más loco viene días después. Está sentada en el consultorio de neurología,
mira al médico a los ojos con una calma absoluta y le asegura que no le pasa absolutamente
nada, que su memoria está perfecta.
Es un contraste brutal, ¿no?
Sí, sí, sí. Y justo hoy vamos a desempacar este misterio en nuestro análisis a fondo.
Tenemos un material clínico fascinante de la Cártedera de Neurología del Hospital de
Especialidades Carlos Andrade Marín.
Un caso súper ilustrativo de la semana 12 a cargo del doctor Alci Torres.
Así es. Y la misión de hoy es ver cómo los neurólogos actúan e como verdaderos
detectives utilizan esta metodología de saber, razonar y actuar. O sea, no solo
adivinan, sino que descifran el cerebro.
Exacto. Y fíjate que el contraste, en este caso que mencionas, es abrumador.
Tenemos por un lado una falla grave en el mundo real, y por otro un cerebro que
pues se niega a reconocer su propio declive.
Es que la hija fue quien la llevó al médico, ¿verdad?
Sí, la hija cuenta que su madre repite las mismas preguntas en un bucle
interminable y algo gravísimo. Ya ha dejado el estufa encendida dos veces.
Uy, quemando las ollas y todo.
Imagínate el riesgo de incendio. Pero, a ver, antes de ponerle una etiqueta de demencia
a esto, la metodología clínica exige establecer una línea divisoria muy estricta.
Claro. ¿Hay que saber si es sololedad o algo más?
Exactamente. La pregunta es, ¿estamos frente a un envejecimiento normal, un
deterioro cognitivo leve o ya es una demencia clínica instaurada?
Porque, seamos honestos, la línea parece súper borrosa desde afuera.
Olvidar dónde estacionaste el auto o el nombre de un actor, pues le pasa a cualquiera.
A cualquier edad, además.
Sí, total. Yo lo pienso como un automóvil. O sea, esos pequeños olvidos son como tener
un rayón en la pintura. Es molesto, se ve feo, pero el auto sigue rodando sin problemas.
Es una muy buena analogía.
Pero ya dejarle estufa prendida a repetidas veces o perder la capacidad de administrar
tu propio dinero, eso ya sugiere que el motor está fallando en serio.
Y esa distinción funcional es la piedra angular del diagnóstico de hecho.
En la práctica médica, esto se define con el criterio cardinal del DSM-5.
¿Y qué evaluó exactamente ese criterio?
Evalúa las actividades instrumentales de la vida diaria, las famosas IADL.
Son estas tareas complejas que, digamos, nos permiten existir como seres autónomos en la sociedad.
Cosas como pagar cuentas o cocinar.
Exacto. Manejar tus finanzas, usar el transporte de forma segura. En este caso, la hija tuvo que
confiscarle las tarjetas bancarias porque la paciente cometía errores catastróficos con su dinero.
O sea, perdió esa autonomía por completo.
Así es. Cuando alguien pierde esa independencia instrumental por un fallo cognitivo,
ahí la medicina cruza la frontera hacia el diagnóstico de un deterioro neurocognitivo mayor.
Aun así, revisando los apuntes clínicos, note que antes de confirmar que este daño es permanente,
los médicos deben descartar un fantasma en la sala de emergencias, el famoso delirium.
Uy, importantísimo.
Y me parece fascinante porque la gente, o sea, en la calle, suele usar delirio y demencia
como si fueran sinónimos.
Sí, todo el tiempo, pero neurológicamente son mundos totalmente opuestos.
¿Cómo los diferencias en la práctica?
Pues mira, el delirium es un síndrome confusional agudo.
Pensemos en un cerebro que sufre un cortocircuito repentino por algo externo.
Una infección urinaria severa, por ejemplo.
¿Una simple infección urinaria te puede causar eso?
Totalmente. Especialmente en adultos mayores.
O una neumonía. O una reacción a un medicamento.
Las toxinas cruzan la barrera del cerebro y desestabilizan todo de golpe.
Y la clave aquí no es la pérdida de memoria, sino la inatención fluctuante.
O sea, el paciente no puede concentrarse en nada.
Exacto, simplemente no puede fijar su atención.
Y claro, si el cerebro no puede prestar atención,
obviamente no va a poder formar un recuerdo nuevo.
Lógico, es el primer paso.
Entonces, para evaluar si esta paciente estaba en delirium o era un daño crónico,
el médico pidió algo súper simple: le dijo, diga los meses del año al revés, desde diciembre.
Una prueba clásica.
Y ella lo logró sin equivocarse ni una sola vez.
Y a ver, eso requiere sostener la concentración un buen rato.
Y al pasar esa prueba, el neurólogo confirma que su red de atención frontal está intacta.
No es un cortocircuito temporal.
Es un apagón estructural que ya lleva como 18 meses avanzando.
¡Wow!
Y ese apagón viene con un síntoma que me dejó pensando.
Lo mencionamos al principio. La anosognosia.
Ah, sí, es quizá lo más duro de procesar para las familias.
¿Por qué es esta incapacidad del paciente para percibir su propia enfermedad, verdad?
Exactamente.
El daño en ciertas áreas destruye el circuito de automonitoreo del cerebro.
No es que la señora sea terca o esté en una fase de negación psicológica.
¿No es orgullo, digamos?
No, para nada.
Físicamente, su cerebro perdió la capacidad de actualizar el concepto de su propio estado de salud.
Por eso jura que sus olvidos son cosas normales de la edad.
¡Qué fuerte!
Bueno, una vez descartado el delirium y confirmada la demencia,
el neurólogo pasa a la fase de razonar.
El segundo pilar de la metodología.
Ajá.
Si hay daño estructural, ¿dónde está exactamente?
Y aquí entra el test de las cinco palabras.
Que… a ver, parece un simple jueguito de memoria.
Sí, parece súper inofensivo.
Pero en realidad es como un bisturí neuroanatómico, ¿no?
Totalmente.
Funciona evaluando las distintas fases de cómo procesamos la información.
Se le dicen cinco palabras a la paciente de distintas categorías.
Y se le pide que las repita de inmediato.
Y ella logró un cinco de cinco en esa primera parte.
Lo cual nos dice que la información entró perfecto por sus vías auditivas.
Y su memoria de trabajo las sostuvo unos segundos.
Pero la verdadera prueba de fuego viene cinco minutos después.
Le piden el recuerdo libre.
Y ahí cero de cinco.
Se esfumaron por completo.
Literal.
Pero aquí el test se vuelve brillante.
El evaluador no dice, bueno, se olvidó, y ya.
Le da una pista semántica.
Lo fascinante aquí es cómo usamos esa pista.
O sea, si la palabra era rosa,
le dicen una de las palabras era una flor.
Eso de esa clave es lo que nos dice dónde está la lesión.
Si fuera una depresión severa,
lo que antes llamábamos pseudo-demencia,
o un problema frontal de concentración,
la pista serviría como puente.
El cerebro diría, ah, claro, la flor era la rosa.
Exacto.
El lóbulo frontal usaría la categoría flor
para bucear en el cerebro y traer la palabra rosa al consciente.
El recuerdo mejoraría un montón.
Yo lo veo como una computadora.
Imagínate que tienes el escritorio lleno de archivos desordenados.
Ajá, un caos total.
El archivo de la palabra rosa está en el disco duro,
pero no lo encuentras.
Darle la pista semántica es como usar la barra de búsqueda.
Escribes flor y ¡pum! aparece el archivo.
Es una excelente forma de verlo.
Pero fíjate que en nuestra paciente,
la barra de búsqueda no funcionó.
No encontró nada.
Con las pistas, solo recuperó una palabra de cinco.
Y peor, tuvo intrusiones.
O sea, inventó palabras que jamás estuvieron en la lista.
¡Wow!
Esto nos da un diagnóstico anatómico preciso.
No es un problema de recuperar el archivo.
Es un fallo franco de consolidación.
O sea, el archivo nunca se guardó.
El botón de guardar se descompuso por completo.
Biológicamente hablando, ese botón de guardar
está en el hipocampo y la corteza entorrinal,
bien profundo en el lóbulo temporal.
¿Y qué pasa ahí exactamente?
Pues esas áreas toman la memoria a corto plazo
y la convierten en conexiones a largo plazo.
Cuando se acumulan proteínas tóxicas ahí,
destruyen esa capacidad.
Ya veo.
Y este patrón donde olvidas rápido
y las pistas no te ayudan nada
es el sello inconfundible de la amnesia episodica,
típica del alheimer.
Entonces ya tenemos el epicentro en el hipocampo.
Pero la evaluación no se queda solo en la memoria, ¿cierto?
Para nada, hay que ver el panorama completo.
Y aquí es donde se pone realmente interesante para mí.
Vivimos en la era digital,
con súper computadoras en el bolsillo.
Y para evaluar el cerebro,
le piden a la paciente dibujar un reloj analógico en un papel.
Sí, el famoso test del reloj, parte de la prueba MoCA.
¿Por qué seguimos usando eso?
Porque sobrevive gracias a que es una prueba
de estrés cognitivo brutalmente compleja.
Para dibujar un reloj, el cerebro orquesta muchas áreas a la vez.
Me imagino.
Primero, la memoria semántica debe recordar
cómo se ve un reloj.
Luego, el lóbulo parietal, que es nuestro mapa espacial,
tiene que planificar cómo poner 12 números simétricos
en un círculo.
Y la paciente dibujó el círculo bien,
pero cometió un error loquísimo.
Amuntó no todos los números del lado derecho.
Dejó la mitad en izquierda en blanco, literal.
¿Qué nos dice eso del cerebro?
Ese hallazgo se llama heminegligencia tensional sutil.
Sugiere que su hemisferio derecho en las áreas parietales
está perdiendo la capacidad de percibir
la mitad izquierda de su mundo espacial.
Increíble que un dibujo te diga eso.
Pero hubo otro detalle con las funciones ejecutivas, ¿no?
Le pidieron marcar las 11 y 10.
Y este es un detalle fascinante del texto.
Ella dibujó una manecilla apuntando al 11
y la otra apuntando directamente al 10.
O sea, no a los 10 minutos, sino al número 10 impeso ahí.
Exacto.
Lo que demuestra un fallo en el lóbulo frontal,
que rige la abstracción.
Para marcar 10 minutos,
el cerebro debe reprimir el impulso de ir al número 10
y hacer la abstracción matemática
de que el número 2 significa 10 minutos.
¿Y ella no pudo frenar ese impulso?
Sufrió un atrapamiento por el estímulo.
Escuchó 10 y actuó de forma literal.
Es asombroso, en serio.
Un dibujo mal hecho te cuenta la historia de daños
en los lóbulos temporal, parietal y frontal a la vez.
Todo en un solo pedazo de papel.
Y con este mapa, pues, el perfil grita Alzheimer.
La señora no tiene temblores, camina normal,
solo tiene estamnesia episodica.
Pero la guía clínica insiste en no confiarse
y hacer un diagnóstico diferencial.
Porque equivocarse aquí tiene consecuencias fatales.
El algoritmo del documento contrasta esto
con otras demencias.
Por ejemplo, la vascular, que viene de microinfartos.
¿Y esa es diferente al Alzheimer?
Sí, progresa de forma escalonada, no gradual,
y daña la toma de decisiones mucho antes que la memoria.
Luego está la frontal temporal, que ataca la conducta.
Los pacientes pierden los filtros sociales
o desarrollan afacias severas.
Y el texto plantea un escenario hipotético
súper interesante.
Dicen, a ver, ¿qué pasaría si la paciente
tuviera rigidez, arrastrar a los pies
y viera gente desconocida en su sala, pero sin sentir miedo?
Si pasara eso, el diagnóstico da un giro de 180 grados.
Apuntaría directo a la demencia por cuerpos de Lewy.
Por las alucinaciones y la rigidez.
Exacto.
Esas alucinaciones visuales tempranas,
las fluctuaciones de alerta y el Parkinsonismo
son la firma de los cuerpos de Lewy.
Pero, a ver, pregunto desde la ignorancia.
Ambas son incurables, ¿no?
¿Qué tan grave es si un médico confunde el Alzheimer con Lewy?
Es un error que le puede costar la vida al paciente.
Espera, ¿en serio?
¿Así de grave?
Así de grave.
En cuerpos de Lewy hay una caída masiva de dopamina.
Si el médico cree que las alucinaciones son por Alzheimer
y le da un antipsicótico típico, como el haloperidol,
para calmarla.
¿Qué pasa con ese cerebro?
Ese fármaco bloquea los pocos receptores de dopamina que le
quedan, provoca una reacción de hiper-sensibilidad.
El paciente entra en una rigidez extrema,
un Parkinsonismo irreversible.
Wow, qué peligroso.
Puede dejar de tragar, tener fiebre alta
y evolucionar al coma o la muerte rapidísimo.
Está formalmente contraindicado.
Definitivamente inegociable saber la diferencia.
Y hablando de salvar vidas, los apuntes mencionan unas banderas
rojas.
Causas reversibles de demencia que hay que buscar con exámenes
de sangre.
Es que hay simuladores clínicos impresionantes.
¿Ví que un simple déficit de vitamina B12 o un problema
de tiroides se pueden disfrazar de demencia?
Sí, la B12 es vital para la mielina.
La capa que aisla los nervios.
Si falta, los impulsos se vuelven lentos y el paciente muestra
confusión y fallas de memorias severas.
También mencionan una prueba de BDRL.
Para descartar neurosífilis, una bacteria silenciosa que devora
tejido cerebral décadas después del contagio,
causando síntomas psiquiátricos brutales.
Y claro, si es eso, le das penicilina o vitaminas y es
como devolverle la mente a la persona.
Exactamente.
Es la esperanza que siempre buscamos.
Otro simulador que me voló la cabeza es la hidrocefalia
normotensiva.
Suena como un problema de plomería en el cerebro.
Y literalmente lo es.
En el cerebro tenemos ventrículos por donde circula el líquido
cephalorraquidio.
Aquí falla la reabsorción.
El líquido se acumula y los ventrículos se inflan como
globos.
¿Y eso aplasta algo importante?
Aplasta unas fibras nerviosas llamadas corona radiata que
controlan las piernas y los esfínteres.
Con razón.
Por eso se busca la treada de hockey madams,
incontinencia orinaria, deterioro cognitivo y una marcha donde
arrastran los pies como si tuvieran imanes, la marcha
magnética.
¿Y cómo se soluciona esa plomería?
Se hace un tap test, una punción lombar para secar líquido.
Al quitar la presión, el paciente recupera la capacidad
de caminar y pensar casi al instante.
Qué maravilla cuando hay solución.
Pero bueno, volviendo a nuestra paciente,
ella no tiene déficit vitamínico ni sífilis y camina perfecto.
Así que descartamos las causas reversibles.
Llegamos a la fase de actuar.
Ya sabemos que es Alzheimer típico.
¿Qué sigue en el hospital?
El protocolo exige imágenes estructurales,
una resondancia magnética para evaluar el daño físico.
Aquí usamos la escala de Scheltens.
¿Qué mide esa escala en la resonancia?
Mide la atrofia del hipocampo.
Vemos cuánto tejido se encogió y cuánto espacio vacío hay alrededor.
Confirma físicamente que el botón de guardar está destruido.
También vi algo sobre una escala de fase cas.
Esa evalúa la carga microvascular.
Buscas cicatrizas blancas que dejan los pequeños infartos
para ver cuánto ha sufrido ese cerebro por problemas vasculares.
Y si conectamos todo esto con el panorama a general,
¿qué significa todo esto para la señora de 74 años?
Porque el texto menciona pastillas como el don e pecilo,
pero no creo que baste con una receta, ¿no?
Para nada, dar fármacos es solo una fracción del tratamiento.
El impacto real en el mundo de hoy es intervenir en su entorno.
Adaptar la casa al cerebro, digamos.
Literal, cambiar la cocina de gas por una de inducción
con apagado automático es obligatorio tras los incendios.
Claro, para evitar una tragedia.
También hay que supervisar cada pastilla que toma.
Si su memoria episodica no sirve,
se puede tomar la dosis tres veces seguidas
pensando que es la primera vez.
Un riesgo de sobredosis altísimo.
Y considerando su desorientación que vimos en el reloj,
el uso de pulseras de identificación que no se puede
quitar o un GPS en la ropa es vital.
Ese nivel de cuidado es lo que separa una catástrofe
de una vida protegida, ¿verdad?
Me parece brillante cómo desarmaron el caso.
Desde unas ollas quemadas hasta maper qué lóbulo fallaba
y cambiarle el estuja.
Es la ciencia pura conectada con el cuidado compasivo.
Totalmente.
Pero antes de despedirnos, esto me deja una reflexión enorme.
Vimos el concepto de anosognosia.
Y esto plantea una pregunta muy pesada para quienes nos escuchan.
Una pregunta importantísima.
Sí.
Cuando el cerebro pierde la capacidad de registrar recuerdos
y encima pierde la capacidad de darse cuenta de que está fallando,
¿dónde reside realmente nuestra identidad?
Es un misterio profundo de la conciencia humana.
Te deja pensando en lo frágil que es todo lo que somos.
Y bueno, con esa reflexión cerramos esta inmersión de hoy.
Gracias por acompañarnos a desentrañar este caso tan
fascinante y tan humano.
Hasta la próxima.